oui
si si si si je vous écoute
mais c'est très grave ce que vous me
prenez là
écoutez je vous remercie beaucoup de
m'avoir prévenu merci c'est ça envoie
vous étiez là c'est parce qu'il vient
d'arriver
figurez vous attendez julie et casimir
arrive vous allez la prendre avant
d'inclure
feuilletait trois fois mais oui françois
raku de nowitzki ce pas ce monsieur
lebreton
a une bonne grippe doit cela bretons le
gardien du phare rire lui même n'a fait
heureusement c'est qu'une petite grippe
ah bon alors dans quelques jours il sera
en forme s'il soigne bien oui sans doute
mais qui va s'occuper de la garde plus
fort pendant son absence mais c'est vrai
on ne peut pas laisser le phare sans
surveillance la moindre balle pourrait
faire ses choux un bateau au je crois
que j'ai trouvé une solution voilà nous
allons nous occuper de la garde du phare
chacun à tour de rôle je veux bien
commencé c'est très facilement sur le
breton a expliqué son travail au jour il
s'agit des lacombe il ya nuit de monter
en haut du phare on allume la grandeur
terne et ensuite on remonte les morts
pour voir si tout marche bien mais
casimir d'une peut pas faire ça tout
seul oui tous quelqu'un pour
t'accompagner comme ça tu pourra dormir
de temps en temps
ah ben voilà monsieur du snob il pourra
très bien faire à faire
vivre ces casiers mieux si tu m'avais
proposé je n'aurais pas refuser et moi
aussi haut mais ne soyez pas vexer vous
vous serez de garde demain a donc fait
très cher à mes bons soit bonjour
monsieur de stress j'ai une mission de
confiance au ska fulbert anselme 19
répondent présents alors allons-y t-il
bien c'est par là venez je vous
expliquerai pour une désignation est
connu
ils s'adorent l'aventuré
[Musique]
un
peu
et
[Musique]
voilà
tu sais françois je serais curieux de
savoir comment monsieur du snob le
casimir ont passé la nuit sans de moi
aussi du temps le temps justement les
voilà qui arrive alors tous les deux ça
s'est pas trop mal passé pas trop mal
merci et vous monsieur 10,9 au ne m'en
parlez pas chez nous non mais vous
parlez en aux biens j'assurais la veille
du fort toute l'année tout seul comme ça
tout seul mais enfin vous deviez vous
relayez vous deviez dormir chacun à tour
de rôle mais oui mais quand tu françois
dans la vie on le fait pas toujours ce
que l'on serait enfin expliquez-vous le
tout les deux eh bien écoutez chers mais
pour mieux vous expliquer je vais
planter le décor non oui ils voient
fassiez vous comment spectacle dans la
très bonne idée allez-y alors imaginons
que le phare c'est le kiosque de julie
on a un peu moins vous quand même mais
bien voilà nous avons commencé par dean
et oui copieusement un peu trop
d'ailleurs un pour une bonne
reconstitution à ce que nous ne
pourrions pas avoir un vrai dit l'un
d'eux kazimierz nycz à l'heure de dîner
d'où étaient tous les deux imaginons que
vous ayez dîner ça suffit pour que s'est
il passé au smap ensuite nous avons
tirées à courte paille oui pour savoir
lequel mon prêt le premier dans le phare
le format du cygne et je suis partie
courageuse mort devant j'ai commencé à
monter l'escalier
rapidement soudas arrivés vers la case
iem marche je suis bloqué le couloir
était plus étroit je me suis trouvée
coincée pas non j'appelle au secours on
se trouve n'écoutant que mon courage je
me précipite pour le bras casimir je
marque beaucoup et je ne donnais pas
c'est cette attention monsieur du snav
gazinet on va lui tomber dessus merci
mes chers amis pour le renseignement
c'est exactement ce qui est arrivé
d'ailleurs monsieur du snob et très
moins elle pourra amortir les chutes
herman aux apparences avait vu 36 chaude
vous êtes sûr pourquoi vous êtes sûr
d'avoir n'avoir eu 36 arabia d'une
expression voyons au 10 36 chandelles
aux minimes et je suis sûr que vous
n'avez pas vu 36 ans a écouté car du mur
que si vous voulez jamais vu un tel
accord même pas c'est trop ça aussi
c'est tout casimir du lait ce monsieur
du snop continuer bon après ce choc
j'ai été obligé de monter jusqu'en haut
du phare puisque kazimi était trop gros
pour passer et pendant que j'allais me
coucher monsieur du snob commençait sa
pénible ascension cusin
143 matchs
exactement étaient encore tu étais tout
droit mais non ça tourne ça tourne à
gauche arrivé en haut pris dans les
langes et tourne encore voulons donner
luc marie nous avait fallu un petit air
de nombreux chers amis ce n'est pas le
moment de présenter je trouve ça ne
s'arrête pas là pourquoi la lanterne ne
marchait pas aux normes marché très bien
c'était merci seulement dans l'essai 143
marché elle avait une de glisse tout
seul ça n'est pas dramatique oui
seulement c'était la toute dernière
et quand je suis tombé
je tombais jusqu'en bas de l'escalier et
ceci toutes les heures au meilleur ami
j'ai mal partout je préfèrerais des
stands est rentré chez moi tout de suite
nos touches pour
ça fera que monsieur du sang